Heeeello  tout le monde c'est Squeezie ! Aujourd'hui on se retrouve pour l'épisode 3 de The Last Guardian!
Voilà je me suis... chauffé pour cet intro et on va baisser d'un ton tout de suite!
On peut donc maintenant donner des ordres à Trico
comme on l'avait vu à la fin de la vidéo dernière.
Alors j'ai fait mes petites recherches hein, mais en fait faut monter entre ses deux cornes
comme ça pour qu'il obéisse aux ordres.
Voilà ou alors c'est une coïncidence foireuse.
Vas-y saute ! Tu l'as vu, tu l'as vu, tu peux sauter.
Voilà il l'a vu et là il va sauter dessus.
Ouaaah ! Tu sautes là-haut ! C'est même pas là que je voulais aller.
Merci mon pote, c'est adorable.
Bon voilà du coup ça va...
Va par là p'tit ***
C'est
la
folie
mon gars.
Donc du coup on est en hauteur. Ah ! Un p'tit levier.
C'est là où on était tout à l'heure.
Haha ! Le fameux levier où on galérait
Fin là où on était dans l'épisode 2.
Hop !
Bah du coup à quoi sert cette grille exactement ?
Ah y'a un bidon de bouffe.
Il est en bas...
Est-ce qu'il peut sauter là ?
Nan il pourra pas lui
On va tester, on va voir.
Saute voir !
Est-ce qu'il va le faire ? Oh il l'a... nan il va le faire ?
J'pense qu'il va juste poser ses pattes de manière à c'que j'aille le chercher.
Ouais c'est ça ! J'arrive mon gars.
Donc il met un petit peu de temps à réagir quand on lui donne un ordre mais c'est normal.
Hop
Allez mange le
Bah là du coup on va pouvoir..
Han.. *Rire*
Oh j'crois que c'est le saut le plus violent qu'on est fait de toutes les vidéos mon gars.. *Rire*
Eh il s'est fait mal !
Oh merde j'me suis fait mal !
Ah je boîte ah nan c'est bon
On va sauter mon grand viens là !
Allez Allez !
Mais me montre pas ton cul !
Ah t'as pas mangé le bidon encore c'est ça ?
Tu attends sagement Trico !
Aie ! Déjà, déjà, contrôle ta queue s'teu plaît !
Donc ouais en fait j'ai dit une grosse bêtise au début de la vidéo, y'a pas besoin d'être entre ses cornes pour lui donner d'ordres
C'est totalement une bêtise. Faut juste en fait relâcher rien une fois que je lui ai donné
Là par exemple j'vais lui dire
Allez on va sauter !
Tu l'as vu ? Ouaaaais... *rugissement de peur*
TricoOOOO !
Laisse moi m'accrocher !
C'est bon, vas-y, tu peux y aller !
*cri viril*
On est toujours dessus ou pas ? *rire* ouii !
Ah ! J'étais persuadé qu'il allait faire un saut mais qu'on allait s'envoler quoi...
Fin sans lui quoi, sans lui dans le vide
Ah y'a un p'tit escalier là, tu l'as vu. Il est là ! L'escalier il est là
*bruit de vache*
C'est bien, c'est bien ! Merci, c'est, c'est à peu près ça, c'est à peu près ça. Reste comme ça c'est à peu - c'est pas mal
C'est pas mal, on a un bon début
*cri de ninja*
Ah c'est bon, c'est passé. Merci Trico ! Tu m'as fait plaisir, là.
T'envoies du rêve, mon che... mon chat.
J'allais dire mon chat mais...
*cri du personnage*
Cette fois, j'me ferai pas avoir
Alors !
On est au-dessus, est-ce que on va pouvoir lui ouvrir ?
Nan...
'tain j'vous rappelle qu'on recherche toujours l'autre Trico hein !
Ce serait ouf d'en avoir deux. T'sais le mec qu'en a pas assez d'un !
Le gars qui veut toujours plus
Euuh par contre ça m'a juste amenéé...
Wouaaaaah...
Ah au-dessus y'a un trou c'est ça ?
Ouais j'pense, ouais c'est ça.
Hop
Et là on se faufile là-dedans ? Vous pensez ?
Ouuiii
Oh ! Premier conduit qu'on prend de tout le jeu, je crois
Fin non on en avait pris un, remarque, avant l'apparition des armures.
Alors du coup on est dedans
Où faut qu'on aille maintenant ?
C'est ça la question. Sans mourrir.
C'est ça la vraie... C'est ça qu'on se pose comme question.
Vas-y lâche-toi. Hop.
Alors...
Au bout là-bas... Je crois que c'est un levier.
Pourquoi il y a un bruit, une musique qui met la pression là ?
Il y a des... D'accord il y a des armures en bas.
Il y a des armures en bas.
Ouah, c'est des sentinelles !
Le problème c'est que là Trico peut pas passer en plus, donc si je tombe, je tombe quoi.
Ah d'accord ! Regardez il y a un levier juste là.
Attends, c'est un levier ou c'est la chaîne qui se tire ?
Wow !
De toute manière de cette hauteur si je descend je vais me casser en deux.
Oh intéressant, ça part un peu en infiltration là.
Hop !
On va avancer.
Moi je pense qu'il faut descendre là.
Ouais mais je vais me fracasse si je descends maintenant !
J'aimerais juste voir si c'est un levier normal où si c'est un chaîne.
Ah c'est un chaîne, je crois.
A mon avis de toute façon faut descendre.
Bon aller de toute façon : "qui ne tente rien n'a rien" comme on l'a vu au dernier épisode.
Ah non mais là...
Ah ouais là mec c'est violent quand même ce qu'il s'est pris.
Ah ouais là, ouais !
Bon en tout cas ils ne nous ont pas repérés.
Ok là je suis prêt.
Alors...
On va attendre.
Putain ça met la pression mec.
On a jamais fait donc j'ai peur qu'on se foirent.
Je sais pas quel est le rayon de vision du truc.
Je le colle d'aussi près que je peux, je pense, sans me faire griller.
Ok c'est parti !
On a très peu de temps.
Aller Trico !
C'est bon il est là !
Oh yes !
Aller mon grand vas-y,
tu rentres, tu rentres, tu rentres, tu rentres !
Vas-y, vas-y, vas-y, vas-y !
Aleer tu passes la !
Vas-y tu passes
YES !!
Euh.. Fais gaffe à ton c**
J'ai dû retirer...
Ok. C'est bon ! Wouhouu
Ok Ca va chier...
Il va les défoncer
J'vais le casser pour le calmer et tout va bien se passer
Bah c'est fini déjà ?
A bah ouf !
C'est bien mon grand, on a gérer là tout les deux !
T'as failli te faire écraser par la porte parce que jme suis chier dessus devant l'armure mais...
voilà jme suis auto-puni donc du coup c'est bien ce que je pensais le 2è levier on va devoir lui
demander de se lever pour pouvoir y
accéder
Hey j'ai pas ta force mon gars jpeux mourir en deux deux
Fait un peu attention à toi quand même
voilà
ah c'est trop cool depuis qu'on peux donner des ordres je trouve ça
plus intéressant encore quoi
il a beaucoup plus de mécaniques, c'est pas juste on monte dessus
pour voir s'il fait quelque chose ou si c'est à nous de le guider
Là clairement c'est à nous de le guider
Ah on va passer la dedans
Les petits pieds nus
ah bah là on a un gros plan hein
Euuuh le fait est que ça m'avance à quoi de faire ça finalement ? Je suppose que jdois faire le tour
Ouais c'est ça
Allez on a pas peur du vide
des tas de gens font ça tous les jours
Fais pas ça mec ! Jme demande quand on va recroiser le... **tain j'ai que ça en tête
Depuis qu'on a vu le 2eme Trico
j'ai que ça en tête mon gars
Ah j'ai trouvé, j'étais en train de rater le trou
Best of euuh
interprétations sexuelles de ce que je dis
y a de quoi faire on trouve
Déjà la dernière fois mon gars c'était abusé
Euuuuuuh
Du coup j'attéris en haut, ah ! ça y est ya re des armures
Ah chui dans un autre hall donc Trico est derrière la porte juste là
en fait
Alors que cette fois yen a 3
Ah va falloir réflechir, ah ouais qui en plus se croisent comme ça
Sachnt que quand jvais sauter... oh pu*** bordel de me***
Oh le con, oh bah en plein dedans !
Allez parfait ! Pafait
En plus j'ai la cheville cassée *rire*
Trico ! *accent italien*
Mi amor !
Mi amor ! AAH
Comment jpeux faire, attend peut-être si jles amène au bout
Non ils vont trop vite j'auais jamais le temps... et si je fais ça ?
Et ouais mon pote comment tu vas me choper là hein
C'est quoi ça AÏE ! AÏE AÏE !
Waouh ok faut y aller maintenant (x4)
Oh yaura jamais le temps
Vas-y Tricoooooo
Ah Trico ils vont me prendre !
Ah ils osent pas... si ils me prennent Trico !
On va refaire la même (x2)
voilà on va refaire la même
Oh mer** ! OH !
Oh d'accord !
ya un passage en dessous !
Comment c'est fourbe ! Personne l'avait vu celui-là
Et là ils doivent se dire "nani?" (quoi en japonais)
où est le petit ?
Et ouais mon pote vous êtes pas malins les gars hein ! Allez vas-y !
Dépêche toi ! (x2)
Avant qu'ils arrivent
Oh les cons ils restent bloqués !
Oh c'est tellement bon, j'ai même pas fais exprès de découvrir ça *rire*
allez on reprend
Allez il arrivent là je sens qu'ils arrivent
Mais on va ouvrir la porte à Trico qui va bien s'énerver
Let's go Trico c'est pou toi !
Voiiilà jte laisse les exploser
Allez de un ! Allez le ptit 2e
Oh tu peux faire 3 d'un coup là
EUH Trico probème !
Chat perché ! *rire*
Ah ils va m'envoyer des sorts le con
Ah jprends cher Trico aide moi
Allez vas-y défonce les, voiilà ils tombent dans le vide.. Ah la grosse mer** !
Ca c'est fait !
alors ensuite
Alors faut refaire pareil c'est ça ? On va accéder au dernier levier, et là derrière la porte
là ya l'espèce de truc
qu'on avait fait tomber dans le vide  tout à l'heure on dirait
merci mon Trico !
petite caresse
Bah ouais faut remercier quand même, il nous met bien
alors on passe de l'autre côté
et maintenant
ya plus de gardes j'espère
Voilà ya ce truc là, jme demande ce que c'est... Hummmm
Ah bah ya un levier tout simplement
On va descendre par ici nous, on y va mon gars ?
allez c'est parti !
du coup ce qu'est ce que c'est que ça
faut que le jette dans le vide encore ou que jle tire vers moi ?
Ah il a peur de ça, il aime pas ça d'accord ! Bon bah jle dégage alors
Whaaaaa
mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ça fout là qui a mit ça là
Hop jlui ai donné l'ordre de sauter
Allez vas-y tu peux le faire
Allez on y va ! HOOOP !
Parfait mon grand !
Ah bah merci mon pote
Il me met direct là où il faut aller, j'avais même pas vu...
Ah bah c'est pas là où il faut aller *rire*
Merci Trico ! AAAAh en fait j'aurais pas dû sauter
J'aurais dû sauter là-bas avec lui mais vu que chui con... Oh mec j'ai foiré
Ouais j'ai foiré (x3) je fais du caca
Pfffffff *rire*
Trico ! comment oses-tu ? Oh chui choqué, bon allez élipse, on se retrouve en haut du caillou
Ok donc cette fois au lieu de sauter à pieds jvais lui dire d'y aller, allez vas-y ! C'est bon il y va
Ok il y est
Vas-y vas-y, t'atteins le pont ou pas Trico ? Ouais tu te retournes et tu l'atteins non ?
Tu peux oui t'es assez grand t'es assez grand
YES !
Whooooo
Ah il a pas peur ce petit hein... Allez !
OOH ! Mais pour lui indiquer de sauter saute pas ! Il est débile lui
Jvais rester accroché
alors là jvais plus rien tenter hein... Vas-y
Ah c'est bon il y va, il est chaud, allez !
on est parti
Yes we can !
Oh jme suis un peu envolé !
'ttention jvais tomber... ok c'est bon
Euuuuh
Et ben voilà !
Nouvelle zone ! On est bien là Trico
Allez on y va mon pote ! Ya des rails... wtf ?
Ya des rails et...
et on est du coup... ya une grille, moi jpeux passer lui pas,
On se refera pas avoir à cause d'une grille
Euuuuh ya rien
Ah d'accord en fait c'est comme une
une chatière j'avais pas vu la 1ère fois qu'il a fait ça
Ah bah voilà le ptit crohet
on a trouvé immédiatement la solution de sortie !! Allez on y va
Nan mais joue pas avec !
Tu m'empêche, c'est un vrai chat lui hein... Mais non !
il se fout de ma gu**le
J'ai compris vas-y joue avec jvais y accéder en te montant dessus
J'ai... la chaîne ! C'est bon chui sur la chaîne, joue pas avec pendant que chui dessus
Sinon ça va être très très violent quand même ce que jvais me prendre
YAATTAA !
Niquel !
Alors on est en hauteur qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir faire du coup depuis cte hauteur
Ah bah un ptit levier ! C'est très bien ça
J'ai même pas vu à quoi il servait
Ah si à ouvrir la...
Laaaa torche en haut de la tour
Il va être attiré par la lumière ?
Ouais, attend j'arrive (x4) attend avant de sauter, c'est bon tu peux y aller
WHOOUU !
Ok donc il est attiré par les flambeaux
C'est noté ! On commence à bien grimper, t'as vu ça Trico ?
Il nous fait faire des trucs de ouf mon gars... Allez j'y vais
Allez à très vite mon grand
Faut que j'aille par là moi, je sais si tu veux me suivre
Non c'est un peu étroit pour toi
Ah ya plein de feu ici !
Tu serais trop content si t'étais venu avec moi Trico
Ok j'ai cru que c'est pas ça qui fallait faire pendant un moment j'ai eu très très peur
et ensuite faut sauter sur la cage et monter la chaîne
Non ? En fait faut que je descende tout simplement chui jamais venu ici
On va faire le tour par là
Hop ok je vois très bien où vous voulez en venir, et ensuite par là
Hop là !
Voilà et ensuite on peut se laisser
Tomber ! **tain il est en train de péter un câble Trico dès que chui loin de lui il devient fou
C'est ouf
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
Oh c'est la potion qui le rend dingue ça ! Vous savez la potion euh du dernier épisode
Qui le rend complètement ouf
C'est totalement ça
OH ! **tain c'est bon , tout va bien
T'es où Trico ?
Ah t'es juste là
Euuuuuh
Ah bah ya un levier
ni plus ni moins
**tain j'ai toujours pas récupéré le bouclier, c'est bizarre
Va falloir que jla prenne et que jlui amène ?
comment je vais faire
pour lui amener alors qu'il ya une grille ? Alors attend...
c'est bon je l'ai
Peut-être qui faut remonter
donc on va remonter
à mon avis je crois qu'en plus c'est ce qui faut faire... Alors attend ça ça s'ouvre ?
On est bien d'accord que ça s'ouvre ?
Qu'est-ce qui ya là ? ouais ouais c'est bon
à mon avis il faut le prendre et le
suspendre au crochet qui est là de base ....
que Trico arrêtait pas de remuer ?
C'est ça ? Si et en le poussnt ça va activer le mécanisme
Ouais c'est ça
ok parfait
Ah il le prend dans la gueule carrément
Nice !
Parfait Tri...
Pwa c'est dangereux !
Fait attention !
*rire*
Déjà ce petit garçon est petit si il se prend cette porte mon gars il va finir
microscopique
Il va être tout tassé...
Ca ça sert à quelque chose ?ouais
Ouais à priori, bon je le fais monter, jvois pas trop où ça peut mener mais...
pourquoi pas... euuuh
ok ça faut le mettre là c'est un poids du coup je suppose que ça va faire quelque chose
Ce truc là veut plus bouger et je comprends pas à quoi il sert en plus
Ah si ! ok faut que jle tire sur le côté maintenant, c'est ça ?
D'accord j'avais pas vu ! On va le pousser par l'autre côté et en fait jpense
qu'on va devoir bloquer la porte avec ça c'est sûr ! hop
On est bon, allez Trico continue de jouer mon grand ! Ouais il t'énerve ce...
Encore un coup !
Vas-y encore un coup !
OUIIIIIII aaah
C'est bon c'est bloqué c'est bon, allez tu viens
Voiilà
Allez tu manges
On ne joue pas avec la nourriture Trico ! Vas-y mange le (x3) avant qu'on bouge
Tiens prends des forces
Bon tu veux pas prendre de forces écoute c'est ton problème hein
Ah ça y est ! T'allais y aller puis t'as vu ta connerie hein
On ne met jamais un hamburger de côté, c'est un proverbe que j'ai inventé ya 1 seconde
Vooiilà !
Maintenant on y va !
Et bim et de un parfait !
Ouh là, mer**
c'est un piège c'est quoi ?
Il voudra pas passer c'est ça ?
mer**
N'ait pas peur c'est des miroirs mon gars ils vont rien te faire
Qu'est-ce qu.. oh c'est quoi ça ?
Ah c'est des morceaux d'armures ok donc jvais devoir l'exciter avec des morceaux d'armures
Et les mettre à côté des miroirs c'est ça ?
D'accord
Attend le casque des soldats il pèse combien quoi *rire* mec sans déconner
Ils ont plus de muscles dans
le coup qu'on a de biceps sans déconner
ça va mieux ? quand je les casse tu te sens mieux ? Pourquoi il a peur de ces miroirs ? **tain
J'ai envie d'en savoir plus, comme les espèces de cristaux bleus qui l'avaient rendu ouf euh
la dernière fois, j'ai envie de savoir ce que c'est
YIIIHIII
Allez quand faut y aller faut y aller, on y va
aalors
On gagne en hauteur hein !
franchement en fait... ouais
on est pas mal du tout
On va descendre, qu'est-ce qu'on a là ?
Ah va falloir péter les...
Woaaaaa là ça à l'air compliqué
WTF, en plus le miroir est protégé donc jpeux pas le casser avec un vase
Alors c'est quoi la mécanique
Ya un truc spécial à faire ?
y'a un truc spécial à faire hein ? Mon ptit doigt me le dit
Ok jpeux l'avancer
Ca tombe ! Parfait ça dégage
OH OH ! TRICO !
Ah jme suis pissé dessus
Toi t'as rien fait
Toi t'es là dans ton petit monde
Bon jvais lui dire de venir
Je sais pas si ça va résister à son poids mais...
Mer** mer** saute Trico
LA QUEUE !
Oh il m'a mit un vent ! *rire*
Mais du coup on fait comment ? Ba ouais on est come des cons, comment on fait ?
Tu viens me chercher ?
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire saute jte rattrape ?
ok
OH !
Merci Trico !
C'était un coup de poker
Heuresement je commence un peu à parler le...
le tricollage hein qui est le langage de Trico
Ouais ça me fait rire *rire*
Alors faut dégager ça ! Un plongeoir fait pour accéder à ce truc
et à libérer Trico
Euuh ouais ouais bah ouais
Euuh va falloir que jle tire mais ça va m'embarquer ... nan jvais faire le tour c'est plus prudent
Alors qu'est-ce que ça va casser cette fois ?
Ca tombe hein jpense que ça va rien embarquer cette fois
Ca tombe ouais
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ? x2
Tu me regardes ?
Ok c'est en train de tomber, chui là !
Oh mer** !
La queue !
La queue la grosse la grosse queue de Trico ! Oh oui !
Merci Trico
Vas-y fonce fonce mon grand chui accroché
Fonce fonce chui accroché t'inquiètes, vas-y go !
Chui là (x3) T'en fais pas chui là
Tiens le coup Trico
Allez Trico vas-y !
Jte carsse (x2) je sais pas si c'est le moment mais...
Ah il est mal là, comment jpeux t'aider ?
Comment je peux t'aider ?
Ah c'est ça vas-y je vais t'aider avec ça, vas-y tiens saisit le tronc saisit le truc
Vas-y tiens tiens tiens saisit le !
Saisit le ! Vas-y vas-y
OUI c'est bon ! Oh **tain
Faut queje m'accroche vite avant que tu partes sans moi  et que tu m'abandonnes sans même te dire au revoir
Vas-y on y va (x4) !
C'était limite mec !
Bravo Trico !
Et bien voilà les mais c'est déjà la fin de ce 3e épisode de The Last
Guar.. Garden ! Le dernier jardin
N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu
Enorme kiff ce ptit euuh total whipe out version Trico
Il a assuré hein jpeux dire que... J'ai envie d'en savoir plus sur l'histoire
pourquoi ya les espèces de gardien ? Tant de questions qui restent
Sans réponse mais nous en saurons très vite dans le 4e épisode
Allez à très bientôt, portez vous bien ciao tout le monde...
Peace !
Jme suis trompé... Peace ! ...
Pardon